Trascrizione: Alexis Gagliardi
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
È il novembre del 2018.
Dieci manifestanti attraversano
gli Champs Elysées,
puntano dritti verso l'Eliseo.
Vogliono manifestare.
La gendarmeria li ferma:
è facile fermarli.
Non sarà così facile fermarli
nei tre mesi successivi:
tre milioni di francesi protestano.
È il fenomeno dei gilet gialli.
Protestano contro l'introduzione
di una ecotassa,
di una tassa che va a tassare
i carburanti, la benzina.
Quindi ha una finalità
tipicamente ambientale.
A loro dire, questo pone
una fortissima ingiustizia,
e pesa sul loro presente
in cambio di un futuro incerto.
Il loro motto, in sintesi, è:
tra la fine del mondo, e la fine del mese,
preferisco la fine del mese.
Piaccia o non piaccia,
giusto o sbagliato che sia,
è un'istanza.
Questo è quello che è
accaduto ai gilet gialli.
Però, in effetti, qual è
il costo di questa decisione?
Qual è il costo della mancata decisione
presa in quel momento da Macron?
La decisione viene respinta,
si torna a consumare carburanti,
si torna ad inquinare.
Qual è questo costo?
Ci viene in soccorso
una ricerca americana, pensate,
una ricerca che parla
del consumo del cibo negli Stati Uniti.
Gli americani spendono
1100 miliardi di dollari
per alimentarsi, per nutrirsi abbastanza.
Però, guardate, ne spendono
una cifra analoga, identica,
per curarsi dalle malattie
del cibo che hanno appena mangiato.
Identica!
Obesità e disturbi del cibo,
diabete eccetera eccetera.
Eppure, ce ne sono forse
un altro quasi miliardo
di 1000 miliardi di dollari
spesi per gli impatti ambientali.
La biodiversità, l'habitat,
la perdita di terreno,
peggioramento delle condizioni ambientali.
Insomma, in effetti si può dire
che spendono 3000 miliardi di dollari.
Ovvero 3.300 $ ciascuno.
Ma qual è la vera spesa degli americani?
Qual è il vero costo
dell'alimentazione degli americani?
È 3.000 dollari?
Io penso che sia, piuttosto, 9000.
3000 sono spesi
per difendersi, per curarsi;
e circa 3000 sono gli effetti ambientali.
Anche qui siamo di fronte
ad un costo implicito di scelta.
E quante sono le altre attività umane
che determinano esattamente questi costi,
e quali sono questi costi?
Dove sono nascosti questi costi?
Chi li pagherà, come e quando?
Quindi le decisioni che prenderemo,
e sopratutto le decisioni
che non prenderemo,
avranno un costo;
e questo costo, prima o poi,
ricadrà su qualcuno.
Ma se questo è vero,
perché è così difficile
prendere le decisioni?
Questo è accaduto pochi giorni fa:
sapete che è accaduto a Roma?
Questo è il G20, che sono le persone
più importanti della terra,
e fino in fondo si cerca un compromesso,
si cerca di differire questa decisione.
Forse questo è dovuto al fatto
che esistono due orizzonti:
un orizzonte di breve periodo,
una decisione difficile da prendere;
e un orizzonte ambientale,
necessariamente un pochino
più spostato in avanti.
C'è questa differenza
fra questi due orizzonti;
e in mezzo a questi due orizzonti
cade la possibilità
di intervenire efficacemente
sulle soluzioni del pianeta.
Eppure,
per un attimo vi chiedo
di dimenticarvi di questi signori.
Vi chiedo tutti, tutti insieme,
di mettervi al posto di questi signori
con le spalle alla Fontana di Trevi.
Perché dico questo?
Dico questo perché è evidente,
da quello che abbiamo sentito
e ascoltato più volte,
che noi siamo responsabili
di questo che sta accadendo;
E quindi, come responsabili
dobbiamo anche essere
parte attiva nella soluzione,
in primis informandoci,
aumentando la nostra sensibilità;
e poi, assumendo delle decisioni attive.
Le decisioni attive sono moltissime,
e possono essere prese quotidianamente:
ne racconto qualcuna.
Pensate, oggi è possibile
non solo scegliersi un volo,
la durata, la destinazione;
ma è possibile scegliersi, anche,
il contenuto carbonico del volo.
Con 20 €, è possibile neutralizzare
l'impronta carbonica ecologica
di un volo da New York
a Città del Capo, andata e ritorno.
È possibile scegliersi gli hotel
a basso consumo energetico,
attraverso un motore di ricerca.
Addirittura, è possibile scoprire
che gli asparagi trasportati via nave,
rispetto a quelli trasportati in aereo,
hanno un contenuto carbonico
enormemente diverso.
Molte di queste decisioni
stanno fra questi due orizzonti;
e sono nelle nostre mani,
sono nelle vostre mani.
Non tutto sarà così facile.
Vi troverete di fronte,
entrando in un supermercato,
esattamente la stessa insalata.
Insalata da due euro al chilo,
da 10 euro al chilo e da 33 euro al chilo.
Appaiono simili, ma non sono simili:
hanno impatti molto diversi sul terreno,
sull'uso dell'acqua, sulla biodiversità.
Eppure, siamo di fronte ad un dilemma:
risparmiare, quindi proteggere
il nostro portafoglio,
e però distruggere il mondo;
oppure decidere di investire,
depauperarsi, ma salvare il mondo.
Questo dilemma, secondo me, si chiuderà.
Si chiuderà per inventiva,
per l'uso del capitale, per le tecnologie,
per gli imprenditori che riusciranno
a portare avanti il loro progetto:
e questo è già accaduto.
È accaduto in molte industrie:
io l'ho vissuto, personalmente,
nell'industria della
produzione del solare.
Pensate, il 90% della riduzione dei costi
in un tempo relativamente breve:
questo vuol dire l'accessibilità,
energia solare dappertutto
a costi molto molto contenuti.
Questo dovete attendervelo,
dobbiamo attendercelo
in moltissime industrie.
Ovviamente, accadrà nell'industria
che ho appena citato;
ma soprattutto, l'aspetto più importante
è che in molte delle industrie nuove,
su cui si gioca il futuro
di questo pianeta,
il capitale e le vostre scelte personali
avranno una grande influenza.
Sono moltissime, pensate.
Sarà possibile modificare -
ciascuno di questi simboli
nasconde un mondo,
nasconde dietro delle scelte coraggiose
di imprenditori, tecnologie, di capitali.
E cambierà il nostro mondo, la mobilità,
cambierà le proteine,
il modo in cui viaggeremo,
la mobilità, le batterie.
Sarà destinato a stravolgere -
il capitale sarà l'enzima
di questa metamorfosi.
Anzi, sarà il vero enzima di una
grandissima e profonda trasformazione.
Capitale che ha le sue incoerenze,
e anche le sue contraddizioni.
Eppure, il capitale sarà destinato
a contribuire a svolgere
questo cambiamento.
In ciascuna di queste icone
c'è in fondo un piccolo Colombo,
un piccolo Cristoforo Colombo
che è destinato a cambiare il destino
di ciascuna di queste industrie.
Ed è già accaduto.
Pensate: Colombo impiegò nove anni
per mettere insieme il capitale
necessario alla sua impresa.
Si rivolse al re del Portogallo,
che era abbastanza
d'accordo, era convinto;
poi ci furono i suoi consiglieri,
che rigettarono:
pensate, l'aggiunta dei matematici.
Poi, dopo qualche anno,
ricorse alla Corte Spagnola.
La Corte Spagnola era favorevole,
ma anche la Corte Spagnola
decise di affidarsi a consulenti,
che bocciarono l'iniziativa.
Attenzione ai consulenti che vi scegliete.
E alla fine, finalmente,
una donna, Isabella di Castiglia,
decide di supportare questa iniziativa,
decide di sostenerla, insieme a Colombo,
che impiega il proprio capitale,
e pensate, insieme all'istituto
di Genova, il credito genovese.
Anche i genovesi decidono di finanziare.
Arrivano finalmente
due milioni di maravedì.
Grazie a due milioni di maravedì,
l'impresa di Colombo prende l'avvio;
e l'estate del 1492, finalmente, da Palos,
esausto, inquieto,
intraprendente, pieno di speranze,
parte alla ricerca del tratto
più breve verso le Indie.
E sbaglia direzione, ovviamente.
Non tutti i business plan
nascono con le ipotesi migliori.
Però è il viaggio più affascinante,
e l'investimento più straordinario
della storia economica moderna.
Il viaggio più affascinante
della storia umana.
Improvvisamente si spalanca un futuro,
un futuro imprevisto
e assolutamente non immaginato.
Lo stesso futuro, adesso, tocca a noi.
E siamo noi a doverci
guadagnare questo futuro.
(Applausi)